l'été est enfin là pour les parcs de
loisirs comme le zoo de thoiry l'espace
rambouillet ou france miniature
ce n'est pas le début des vacances mais
au contraire la période la plus chargée
de l'année
ici l'on sait des loutres d'asie les
plus petites routes qui existent par
rapport aux 13 sous-espèce alors elles
font entre 70 et 80 cm pour un poids de
4 à 5 kg à peu près plus de mille
animaux sur un domaine de 150 hectares
de quoi attirer près de 450 mille
visiteurs par an le parc animalier de
thoiry et le troisième site le plus
visité d'île de france hors paris et le
parc de loisirs le plus attractif des
yvelines
l'affluence estivale demande de
l'organisation les 57 employés sont
rejoints par près de trente saisonniers
comme fiona elle est ici pour deux mois
tu peux être très polyvalent parce que
généralement on peut être au péage le
matin pour l'accueil des clients en
revenir après la boutique des fois il
faut aller dans restauration et après on
revient sur les différents points de
vente du personnel venu prêter main
forte pour accueillir le public dans le
parc france miniature près de 35
contrats saisonniers sont signés le
nombre d'employés passe ainsi
progressivement de 12 à 50 entre le mois
de mai le mois d'août le côté jardinage
désherbage aux arrosages qui revient
mais les peluches nettoyer les cours
d'eau pour l'heure beaucoup d'entretien
bouconne nettoyage l'emploi généré par
les parcs de loisirs est un enjeu majeur
pour les collectivités en poste
permanent entraîne entre un et trois
recrutements saisonniers une logique due
à l'activité dite de loisirs et
touristique
on est sur un fonctionnement très
saisonnier ici c'est à dire que
clairement la haute saison pour nous ça
2 avril jusqu'à fin octobre et en
particulier par exemple mais juin c'est
vraiment le pic on l'a des journées
jusqu'à 1000 1500 voire 2000 p vetter
cent mille curieux se pressent chaque
année au parc forestier animalier de
rambouillet pour observer les animaux en
liberté et les aigles et rapaces des
visites plus étalée dans le temps qu zoo
de thoiry
chaque week-end entre mai et septembre
près de 3000 personnes s'y rendent
on a besoin de plus d'accueil plus de
caisse plus de renforts au restaurant et
dans les points de vente
donc ça au niveau du personnel c'est un
fait après on a des tâches différentes
même pour ceux qui ne sont pas
saisonnier entre les billets la
restauration et la vente de produits
dérivés
un week-end à thoiry équivaut à près de
cent mille euros de chiffre d'affaires
en deux jours pour le parc
la haute saison représente en moyenne
60% du chiffre d'affaires global à
l'année des parcs de loisirs avec ses 5
hectares et ses 117 monument historique
à l'échelle 1 30e
le parc france miniature d'elancourt à
vocation pédagogique ne peut maîtriser
tous les paramètres d'une saison réussie
le parquet en extérieur sur plus de 95 %
de sa surface donc la météo est un
facteur essentiel sur une journée with
bleus une journée où fait très beau on
va à peu près multiplier la
fréquentation par 4 ou par 100 cas la
météo un impondérable pour les parcs
mais pas seulement ces structures sont
soumises a plus d'aléa qu'on ne pourrait
l'imaginer notamment à cause de la
clientèle on essaie aussi nous de faire
démarrer la saison de plus en plus tôt
alors cette année on a quand même eu des
soucis avec le plan vigipirate ce qui
fait que les écoles ne sont pas du tout
venu en mars avril alors que d'habitude
avec des ateliers et des promos on
arrive à les faire venir plus tôt donc
là tout s'est concentré avec les ponts
dès le début de la saison pour les
individuels juin les scolaires qui
n'avait pas du tout réservé avant donc
laissé précipiter un petit peu et
c'était plus courts cette année les
petits visiteurs une cible non
négligeable à france miniature ils sont
plus importants que la clientèle
étrangère qui ne représente que 5% des
visites à l'année les écoles elles
viennent beaucoup à france miniature
dans le cadre de la de la sortie de fin
d'année voilà donc on est très fréquenté
par les écoles de la mi-mai à la fin
juin là on attaque les grandes vacances
est un petit peu de centres de loisirs
mais la partie école c'est presque 12 %
de la fréquentation du parc sur l'année
mais très concentrées sur le mois de
juin championne mans si on disons le
marché des parcs à thèmes est passé de 3
à 35 millions de visiteurs par an les
visites de groupes scolaires seniors et
comités d'entreprises diminuent au
profit des familles ou amis à l'espace
rambouillet 80% des recettes viennent de
la billetterie sixième site le plus
visité des yvelines son chiffre
d'affaires s'élève à 1 million d'euros
une somme presque équivalente à celle
nécessaire à l'entretien du parc
on a besoin aujourd'hui de rajouter un
petit peu en fin d'année pour un poids
équilibré mais alors les dépenses c'est
la main d'oeuvre les équipes
et puis toute une partie aussi de
faut nourrir les animaux et puis des
dépenses classiques d'entretien
d'infrastructures sur le site quoi il ya
un investissement de l'eau nf pour
boucler le budget annuel
l'espace rambouillet des bourses 40000
euros chaque année pour compléter
l'alimentation de ses animaux sauvages
c'est moins que les 400 tonnes de
nourriture achetée chaque année à thoiry
pour ses pensionnaires du côté de france
miniature les charges d'exploitation
s'élèvent à 2 millions d'euros par an il
appartient au groupe grévin et compagnie
également propriétaire du parc astérix
comme touahri le parquet privé et ne
peut compter sur aucune aide ni
subvention
les deux lieux sont dans le classement
des 15 sites français qui attire plus de
trois cent mille visiteurs par an la
solution pour rester attractif et
rentable se renouveler en permanence
cette année thouars innove en
accueillant saisine aux orres
animatroniques un investissement de 300
mille euros pour une durée de trois mois
ça pousse à la revisite aussi on sait
que dans un parc zoologique les
visiteurs viennent à peu près tous les
trois-quatre ans le fait d'avoir une
expo quelque chose de phares
d'événements tous les ans je pense que
ça leur donnera aussi envie de revenir
parce que les animaux c'est toujours
différent un parc animalier ça se
renouvelle donc si en plus on appuie sa
avec un évènement saisonnier je pense
que ça sera sympa
une problématique différente pour le
parc forestier de rambouillet
son objectif fidéliser une clientèle
plus à la recherche d'immersion dans la
nature que d'évènements temporaires
on peut dire aujourd'hui avec un recul
de 40 ans par rapport au parc animalier
et de 20 ans par rapport à l'espace
rambouillet il ya il ya une vraie place
qui était trouvé et ça correspond pas
dire un public qui recherchent une
expérience nature est un petit peu
apaisées un point important c'est que il
ya à peu près 40% de nos visiteurs qui
reviennent en fait france miniature
développe plus l'évolution de son offre
en proposant des innovations ludique et
en misant sur l'interactif en complément
de ces maquettes bilan à la fin de l'été
2015 si le public est au rendez vous
mais les directeurs de parcs sont
confiants ce qu'on constate ici à france
miniature d'hommes dans de nombreux
parcs c'est que les français ont l'air
de 2
- se pénaliser sur leurs loisirs et
beaucoup de parcs y compris nous qui
ferons une année 2015 meilleure que
celle de 2014
pour l'instant la météo nous aide
beaucoup depuis quelques mois mais on
pense aussi qu'il ya un petit
desserrement du porte monnaie des
français sur les loisirs qui est
favorable à l'ensemble des parcs
d'attraction ou les eaux enfin les sites
de loisirs en général
avec ses 200 parcs de loisirs la france
se place au 5e rang mondial sur ce
secteur et les civils ne devrait pas
être en reste
un projet de parc d'attraction d'une
vingtaine de manèges est en discussion
il devrait voir le jour en 2020 sur la
zone commerciale d'orgeval